nos piden que factor hicimos 25 x 4a
menos 30 x cuadrada más 9 y lo primero
que veo aquí es que nos podemos asustar
bastante porque tenemos una x 4a y
después tenemos una x cuadrada y nunca
habíamos visto algo así podemos entrar
en pánico esta es una de las opciones o
la otra opción es que pensemos que tal
vez de pura casualidad éste sea un vino
en el cuadrado perfecto porque fíjate
bien 25 x 4 tiene raíz cuadrada exacta y
9 también tienen raíz cuadrada exacta y
qué tal si esto es un binomio cuadrado
perfecto pues aquí en medio tendremos
que tener dos veces el primero por el
segundo déjame explicarte un poco mejor
y hacer un poco de cuentas mejor voy a
sacar este paréntesis de aquí y voy a
decir que 25 x cuarta es exactamente lo
mismo que 5x cuadrada elevado al
cuadrado fíjate que 5 por 5 me va a dar
25 y x cuadrada al cuadrado me da x
cuarta y por otra parte tengo que en la
raíz cuadrada de 9 es más menos 3 es
decir más 3 elevado al cuadrado me da 9
y menos 3 elevado al cuadrado también me
da 9
por lo tanto lo único que hace falta es
verificar y revisar que en medio
estuviera dos veces el primero por el
segundo 5x cuadrada elevado al cuadrado
me da 25 x cuarta más tres o menos tres
al cuadrado me da nueve y de hecho
tienen que ser menos porque si te das
cuenta porque si quisiéramos que fuera
un mínimo al cuadrado perfecto en medio
tendría que estar dos veces el primero
por el segundo y es negativo entonces me
quedaría 2 por 5x cuadrada por menos 3
cuando estoy multiplicando por menos 3
se vuelve negativo y fíjate que vamos
bien porque queremos llegar a menos 30 x
cuadrada y de hecho 2 por 5 10 por menos
3 me da menos 30 x cuadrada que en
efecto es el término que está en medio
de toda esta expresión y bueno por lo
tanto podemos concluir que en efecto
esto es un binomio cuadrado perfecto
ahora como escribimos su factorización
bueno pues esto ya está muy sencillo
esto es exactamente lo mismo que el
primer término que encontramos es decir
la raíz cuadrada de 25 x cuarta que eran
5x cuadrada ya esto le voy a quitar tres
menos tres esto elevado al cuadrado
dicho de una manera de su mínimo
cuadrado perfecto o también
podemos ver como 5x cuadrada menos 3 que
a su vez multiplica a 5x cuadrada menos
3 y ya con esto encontramos la
factorización de esta expresión que yo
tenía aquí